right
this is just a very short uh clip just
to
give you some idea of the detail that i
put into my teaching
i've always been i think my past life as
a
working as a micro mechanic so my brain
obviously
likes to take things apart and
uh and looking at them you know how do
they work
so i think cytosensei who i ended up
with
as my main teacher
he must have done similar things because
he would
keep creating more and more uh ken and
joe
far more than what i've sensed he left
us so really we're doing the weapons i
think today
of uh cytosensing not i sensing
but saying that we've done it and a lot
of people around the world you you want
to do
weapons especially if you're unable to
do thai jiu-jitsu right now
so i'd like to just go through a few
things
if you want to be a martial artist you
have to
not be a child or some kind of uh
you know superhero you know you're a
human being
it takes a lot to become a martial
artist
if you watch the shell in monks come
forward and watch the rigorous
workouts that they do they're
spectacular to watch
we're never going to get anywhere near
that you might as well
forget that idea unless you're going to
really really devote yourself a
very young age and if i'm talking to a
five or six year old now
then good luck to you if i'm talking to
a 20 year old
do the best you can with within the next
50 years because uh
that's how long i've nearly been doing
it and i'm still studying as a student
okay so what what what are the points on
this uh
this quick video today
you'll notice uh if you look closely my
joe
is placed near my big toe it doesn't
want to be outside the big toe
or too far into the foot it wants to be
in between the big toe
and the the next toe shall i look down
to check it
okay so i'm going to check it up it's
it's out
so i'm going to put it where i want it
to be
so so you can look down to check it
but the biggest thing you'll find with
even the top iwala
teachers i do carters
you know and now and their head will
drop
like that okay so you'll see them
you know doing
and then they you know be really serious
really marshall
and then their heads will drop when they
put it back down
if you don't know you're looking for
this you won't notice it
but if you take the time on youtube to
look at something you'll notice they're
doing it
okay some not everybody but we weren't
trying to do that
since he used to say you should know
where your foot is
i'll come a little closer just so you
can see the points here
my hand shouldn't be casual it shouldn't
be loose
it shouldn't be too far down too far up
right if i took my hand off it would be
in line with my navel
okay so put it out there it's in line
with my navel
wants to be natural this isn't natural
you know actually
if you let it go will go down there if i
let it go down there you'll notice the
little fingers not on that
in weapons ken and joe the little finger
first
hugs it then the next finger the rest
are just
wrapped around it they're not really
doing a great deal
it's them two fingers that are important
why am i going on so much about this
detail because it's important
okay so you don't look down you grip
with with the two first two fingers
and then the next thing is don't lean
forward
when you go to pick up your joe don't
lean forward like that
you're going across the line
again since he said hide behind your joe
of course the size of my jaw and size my
body
i can't hide behind it so but my
thought process can go oh i need to be
thinking as small as possible so it's it
it's the attitude that you're finding
out about here
the attitude not just casual
oh well i just pick my joe up i'll ski
the next thing is um if you go against
the wall
and you're going to pick your joe up
not to bring this round but to soften
the knees stretch the arm
but first it'll be difficult i'll come
closer so you can
you can see don't worry about the feet
they're stationary
i soften the knees this i'm touching the
joe now
and i've got the joe i've got the joe
you most people are doing this all right
or they pick it
or they pick the joe up and put it in
that
in this hand while you're picking it up
if someone else has a joke
they could knock it so say she said
don't
don't pick your joe up one-handed make
sure that
you have two hands on the jar two hands
d on the jaw two hands
on the jaw
soften the knees stretch get it ski
soften stretch skin
soften the stretch ski
next point i'll pretend this is the war
i pretend this is a war for now a lot of
people
they not only do they all do this wrong
but let's say
i soften i don't bring the shoulder
around i get it
they now go like that you see it going
backwards it's going backwards
it's going backwards my front hand is
doing nothing it's going backwards
that means that when i go forwards my
partner would have to see an
opening to come in
so a good test is to stand against the
wall
stand against the wall
and you go forward stand against the
wall
and you go forward please do it
on a wall that doesn't matter because
i'm not going to do it because i respect
my walls
but a lot of people
will hit the wall so it's best to do it
try it 20 centimeters 30 centimeters try
it
a few centimeters off because when you
get the
thunk funk you're gonna feel really
embarrassed
see here's the wall
i come down okay there's the wall still
you see my hand here
all right not not
this
so that's so there's the test for the
wall okay
i'm gonna go into a great bit more
detail on my
in my patreon page so if you want to be
a contributor to that
we're going to go in fine detail build
up all these precision
things and uh before you know where we
are
you're like you know be going up and up
and up in a martial attitude
it's aikido's called a martial art it
means it's a fighting buddha it's a
fighting
a way of fighting not that we want to
fight
we want to defend we want to
please go past we don't want to fight
you
but if you're making stupid errors
you know you're sort of just going down
here
picking it up pulling it back
skiing looking down
it it's immature it looks terrible to
to the person that knows i hold
cytosenses weapon scrolls
so this means that he's allowed me
to teach the weapons he has confidence
in me
i remember doing my first weapon scroll
three times i didn't pass
uh sorry i didn't fail
then well i had to do it three times i
passed on the first
time because i was so scared and so
precise and so
you know giving him what he was looking
for and also
achieving something myself what i done
was he said
this is how it's done so when we went on
a large seminar somewhere in the world
he would say tony get out there and do
it but i'm watching you
and he said you're being tested every
time you're out there
so i had to do that three times in
different places around the world
and i felt as if i was taking my test
all over again
so be precise please
become a contributor if you wish to
patron if you don't wish
that's fine i hope this will give you
enough to start
you're becoming a little sharper thank
you for your time